quick pre-roll thank you to the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by squarespace click the link below
get to building that online business
presence of years but first
we have work to do
[Music]
the little things so the little things
is written and directed by john lee
hancock and it's this month's hbo max
warner brothers exclusive what do they
have like
one coming to hbo max every month what a
bad business model it's a crime thriller
starring denzel washington romney malek
jared leto and it has a plot that you've
seen a hundred times over seriously
i mean that's being generous i should
say a thousand times over here it is
denzel's the former city cop turned
small-town cop who returns to the city
very briefly but he notices this crime
scene this murder investigation
is very familiar to him from when he was
a city cop so he stays in the city to
work with this new hot shot detective
and they're gonna work together to try
to solve the case a hundred times over
which is fine you can have a plot that
you've seen a hundred times or a
thousand times over as long as it feels
fresh as long as the movie gives you
that hook something that you can just
bite onto something compelling but it
doesn't i mean the cast
is great like it's a great cast on paper
and i feel like they were banking on
that they were like we don't really have
anything
particularly original in here so
hopefully the cast is
what brings people to the theater i know
denzel's fine rami malek's
fine jared leto's typecast that's what i
can say about it it's a great cast who
did the best they could do
given the material they got but you
really feel like the movie was cast
based on the typecast like all right we
need an older big city cop turned small
town beat cop who returns to the big
city detective oh denzel
perfect young hot shot up and coming
detective romney malek just got an oscar
perfect and last but not least your
basic homeless hobo looking weirdo
jeremy johns
shut up jared leto jinx jared leto's
that now he's he's that type of
weirdo so he's that weirdo who talks
like this
and never really blinks in this movie he
is the same weirdo
that he played in blade runner 2049.
just imagine that guy got new
eyes and lost all of his money because
he put all of his money into gamestop
stock when it was at its height before
it crashed
being worth the buck 75 in store credit
and he looks like he lost all that money
but he still acts the same
that's his character here it wasn't
enough for me i felt like the actors in
this movie had enough to be told hey
just kind of do what you do and that's
the thing no one really makes the roles
their own they're just they feel like
they're going through the motions and
they don't put that on them
we know they're great actors we've seen
them give a lot of great performances
denzel is at the top of that list but
there's just not enough in this script
for them to make it their own and that
brings me to denzel and rami malek
they're the two working together i
didn't
feel any of that chemistry here i'm not
trying to compare this movie to seven
i'm just saying if you can have a murder
mystery cop investigation in which you
have one cop and another cop
separated by an entire generation and
they're working together they've never
worked together before but you know
they're trying to solve this case and
in seven it completely works at first
they're not super close but you feel
that cop
relationship build i didn't get any of
that here just felt like a couple people
clocking in for the day like all right
we're here when they say action we go
home when they say cut this bum yeah
because i know the actors in here have
so much more to give i started this
video about pretty pessimistic to be
honest with you i mean
it starts out compelling enough this
girl's being chased she's trying to run
from
some [ __ ] you don't know who it is
but from the get-go i was like this is
pretty compelling stuff i'm digging this
i'm liking it and then it just
it gets going and i'm like go back to
when this movie was compelling it's like
the more
data and information you get in this
movie the less interesting it starts to
be
and in the end it does take a swing at
having this unconventional
compelling cerebral ending going on but
it wasn't it just didn't work it wasn't
that it's a swing and a miss but when
you give it your all with that swing
when you strike out it's still a
strikeout not like it's like
yeah but i really tried all right yeah
you did take a base awesome though given
enough time i imagine that will be the
rule in baseball soon enough this is a
movie that isn't quite as smart as it
wants to believe it is
and while it's walking you to this point
of unfulfillment you're just checking
your watch
i just so many times because it's
streaming i just push the button like
okay
all right we're an hour into it got
another hour to go yeah i'm just
babbling at this point i already gave
you the hint i'm not gonna remember this
movie in t-minus one day
yep already forgot and again thank you
to the sponsor of this video this video
is brought to you by squarespace the
all-in-one platform to build your online
presence and run your business they sell
over 200 top level domains so you can
find that perfect name for your website
there are no hidden fees or price hikes
so buying a domain on squarespace is
very simple but more than that in this
world of increasing online business it
really is
a hub to get that online business of
yours going you can present your videos
from youtube vimeo or animoto on your
squarespace site every design
automatically includes a unique mobile
experience that matches the style of
your website you know how many of my
views are on mobile phones
a lot so squarespace offers you a free
trial so get on that because
free is good free is right free
works and when you're ready to take that
plunge click the link below go to
squarespace.com
jeremyjohns get 10 off your first
purchase of a webpage or domain and
thank you once again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right so the
little things have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite investigative murder mystery
detective movie whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you